hello everyone
uh welcome back uh if you're watching my
previous lecture this is uh
jim joshua once again and i'm going to
be showing you the games
of the week welcome back and i should
mute my volume so you don't have to hear
me twice
um anyway welcome back uh to my lecture
so uh today i'm going to be
showing a couple olympia games i went
over some on the live stream
on wednesday i went over a game of raise
and a game of annie's
uh today i wanted to focus on a couple
games of wesley's
uh i'll do the first i'll see how long
the first takes honestly and then if
it uh we have plenty of time i'll
definitely show at least some of the
second
um because they were both like really
interesting games
but i want to get through them uh as
much as we can
so
wesley is black in this game against
nikolai noritsen
um a very strong i am from canada
so this was in the canada usa match and
for those of you wondering i think
we are playing i think china later
tonight or something i i actually
haven't checked yet uh today's been a
little crazy
but definitely it's a fun event to
follow
um and yeah this game was quite
something
so b3 so noritsen plays like all sorts
of openings he's uh a little more
unconventional as a player so you just
kind of get a position which can be a
lot of fun
uh to kind of watch so oh
india beat china but i thought china
still made it
and i thought they were playing ukraine
actually so
uh i think they beat china earlier maybe
but china still was the one who
qualified
um in any case uh so yeah we have
uh northside against wesley
and wesley one of the things i've
noticed about wesley
ah ukraine one okay so ukraine beach uh
ukraine beat china so i guess we're
playing ukraine probably tomorrow
morning i want to say um i know a couple
of the people on the team and they tell
me things but i forget things so
any case i'm bad for infight info for
that reason
in any case um one of the things i
noticed about wesley is that he's
extremely efficient at beating low-rated
players like he often demolishes them
and it sounds like a simple thing but
you take a player one of the prime
examples i always thought of was peter
leko
who would play super tournaments and
often win them like do really well
just super solid player but he grew up
in round robins
and when he played open tournaments he
would play fine but he would often give
up a lot of draws to say
25 50 gm's you know uh which you know
i'd like to think we're not terrible but
quite honestly the difference between
someone like leko and someone like me is
really huge
uh and that you know he would give up
draws just because he plays very solidly
it was quite something and one of the
things i noticed about wesley is even
when he plays 26 2650
he often just smashes them he makes them
look really bad
and i don't know if it's part of his
style he just learned to do it playing
open events
uh no i don't i am not related to
frederick um
but uh yeah he's probably maybe the most
famous freedom in the chess world uh the
chess space
he's the one who did chess base
um so anyway uh so we'll see b3
e5 bishop b2 knight c6
e3 d5 so you have lots of options here
you can play e4
you can play d5 one of the systems i
always found
kind of amusing against this was you
play net f6
and then you play here the idea being
that normally this is a weird move but
the point is if they take on c6 you play
d takes
your pieces look kind of nice actually
so white offered plays here and then you
have many options but
the most amusing to me was actually
going back
so the idea is that if they take here
you take
the pawn can't be captured due to this
so they have to play like if they play
knight c4
you just play d6 and now the bishop
makes sense when he's seven so i'm not
saying this is absolute best this is
perfect this is a playable for black as
far as i know
but i just always found that line really
funny because you play like knight f6
bishop d6 bishop back
so d5 was played though which of course
can't be too bad putting pawns in the
center
but it does allow white to play bishop
b5 trying to target them bishop d6
knight f3 and wesley plays f6
so the move f6 is one of those that it
can get you into trouble in lots of
positions
but there are certain positions where
it's quite allowable
uh or not allowable but quite playable
due to various reasons
and one of the ones that you see you see
it more when white does it
when black it like say in a queen's
indian black has a piece here and a
knight here
that you put the pawns on f3 and e4 and
it dulls them
in this case we see kind of the opposite
thing
we see that these pieces are are aiming
at your center so you play f6 e5 and
these pawns are very annoying for white
to deal with
um because they dull both the pieces
and you also have to make sure when you
play a move like this that you do not
of course allow this diagonal to get
weakened but because the bishop's on b5
it might give itself away it's not very
active
you're able to play a move like this um
but i get asked this a lot because it's
one of those things that it looks like
kind of a
slightly weakening move but it can often
be
um quite okay here
i don't know about move two because if
you played on move two white's not
committed to putting the net in f3 i
might put the knight on e2 where it's
better positioned against this for
example
i'm not saying putting in a move there
i'll move to is terrible but i think
that sometimes it's nicer to wait til
your opponent commits their pieces first
uh so
c4
a6 now you take take
so you have almost like a weird french
type position in reverse i want to say
um it's one of those things that it's
hard to say like if you're ever unsure
if you think it's probably weakening it
it probably is
but there are so many cases where
especially if your opponent's going to
give up their bishop like in a lo in an
exchange lopez you play f6 all the time
and because white doesn't have a bishop
it's just no big deal you know so there
are plenty of situations where it's
perfectly fine
um yes feingold's rules you never play
f6 honestly if you never play it you'll
run into trouble a lot less
but i would say that there are certain
situations where you really have to
avoid moves like this and certain ones
where it's okay here
white's missing a light squared bishop
and the knight on f3 and bishop b2 are
perfectly dulled by those pawns
so here i would say feingold's rule does
not reply
but yeah i would say it's definitely
very french-like especially
if d4 ends up happening so d4 does end
up happening actually e4 knight g1 so
this is very much a french in reverse
um so along that vein uh wesley plays a5
which is a very typical french idea that
you want to
get uh to keep in mind we're basically
playing a winner where with reverse
colors the idea being of course to get a
bishop there where it's going to be
very nasty on this diagonal so it's a
very very common idea
of course playing f5 was also doable
uh knight c3 was played and here wesley
played maybe the one move of the game
which i almost don't understand
so maybe you guys can explain to me i
thought for sure he would play the move
actually let me forget that for a moment
what would you guys play here
because i'm curious if any of you even
come up with this move
it was a little bit surprising to me
a4 is interesting just trying to push
the pawn usually though you don't try to
push it that fast but
um it's probably playable
so f5 i think is what i would play i
mean i guess he's worried about just
grabbing this pawn but
ugh that's that's an
ugly pawn to take
i mean you have so many options you can
take it back you can play bishop a6 at
some point
um i don't know it was it's very
surprising to me if this pawn is
easy to capture moves like queen g5 come
into into mind where you're trying to
take on g2
uh and not to mention just all the weak
squares like here um
the bishop comes out to a6 is just so
nasty um
a lot of different ideas um but he came
up with the move bishop b4
i'm guessing he was just really scared
of this pawn hanging but to me the move
bishop b4 felt kind of weird because
the bishop is so much better on d6 and
it's felt a little bit strange to put it
on b4 at the moment
but again i think that he was just
worried about the the pawn on d5 but
it's still a little bit strange
so knight to esa e2 was played 97
castles and this is also kind of an
interesting moment
um so wesley could play the move bishop
a6 immediately putting pressure on the
pawn
and this would maybe save him a little
bit of trouble
but he castled which seems like of
course a very natural move
but nine nikolai plays the move knight
a4
and we realize that
black maybe has a slight problem what is
the problem that wesley is now facing
and again maybe he saw this all in
advance but
i'm guessing he either underestimated or
missed this move
keep in mind it's game 15 right so our
standards for
the top players are not quite the same
what is he missing here what's going on
and the bishop on b4 can't get out right
if you try to play bishop to d6
then c5 if you wait then i play c5 and
that bishop's just trapped
bishop a6 is a possible move here but i
can still play this and your bishop is
still stuck from what i can tell
so the bishop on b4 is actually a real
problem here
um like you could just lose it and this
is one of those things that
if you're not careful in the opening or
after the opening it's something that
you can that can happen to you and that
can be really really bad
so you have to be careful when you put
pieces on squares like b4 it's one of
the reasons why
i was really surprised by wesley's
decision i thought that he would for
sure
just gambit the d5 pawn and continue for
the initiative
um so the question is what should wesley
do
because he came up with something really
really cool here to try to counter uh
nikolai's idea
so black to play again i'm not just
looking for a move i'm looking for an
idea
and you know a variation if you guys
want to really impress me
i'm very impressed by variations i see
moves all the time
so you guys are talking about the move
c5 for white which
for black which i understand but there's
still a3 as far as i know trapping your
bishop so i don't know if it actually
helps us
because then we're trapping our own
bishop
so bishop a6 is possible but again it's
just one move right you need a solution
to c5 so once again i'm looking for more
than just a move
so i'm seeing a variation with two moves
uh dc bc rook b8
but i still don't see what you do
against a move like a3 for example or
c5 i i don't quite see your defense
so keep in mind uh zeeshan that after
knight f5 i'm not gonna play a3 i'm
gonna play c5
so i'm not going to give you the
opportunity to go back to e7 that's the
whole idea
so after c5 once again uh deep mined i'm
not going to take on d5 i'm just going
to play a3
i'm just going to trap your bishop so
none of you have really
spotted the idea and again i'd say it's
more outside the box thinking there are
different ways to respond to a threat
you guys are all really trying actively
to prevent the threat to try to counter
it which is
one of the ways to handle it and makes a
lot of sense
but sometimes that's not really the
option that you have to look for
sometimes you have to look for what else
can i do maybe i can
distract them elsewhere maybe i can try
to do something else so
gill's suggesting bishop d6 c5 bishop
takes h2
the problem is it makes a lot of sense
by the way what you're saying but the
problem
is that you're not really targeting a
weak spot on the king side because king
takes h2 and
you don't have knight g4 check queen h4
which is usually the follow-up to that
attack
um so that's not really where
that's not really where white's weak so
you have to ask yourself where is white
really weak in this position
and that's what you have to try to
exploit that's what you have to try to
attack here
so the h2 pawn the dark squares is not
really where i'd say white's weak
so where do you think white is a little
bit weak and where you can try to target
your attack
so again i'm seeing individual moves you
should know how i feel about them by now
but d takes c4 b takes c4 and you're not
helping yourself yet
you
yeah do not see the idea yet
but take your time again ask yourself
where is white week here that's kind of
the key here
because bishop d6 takes h2 again you're
kind of in the right idea you're in the
right ballpark but
h2 the dark scores are not weak
ah gill's getting the idea very nice
so wesley played knight g6 here
and the whole point is that your your
bishop can go back to e7 and if you
allow the bishop back to e7
you're kind of abandoned your king side
so you have to at least try to trap that
guy
so nikolai does and then net h4
and this is actually quite an incredible
position
um because basically he's saying half my
bishop keep in mind it takes quite
several moves white has to play c5 white
has to play a3 why does to take it
and he's saying look your g2 pawn your
light squares around the king
are very vulnerable and
he's basically saying that if you try to
take my bishop i'm just going to mate
you
so let's see how this actually works
whether it does let's say white does
play a3 it wasn't what was played in the
game
but what could you do here
so bishop g4 ic suggested this is a nice
move
so yeah if a takes b4 you play knight
takes g2 and this is very very strong
because if king takes bishop f3 check
and then queen d7
and the queen's coming into the party
it's going to be
very very bad um
so
however bishop g4 a move like h3 might
be a better defense here
but notice how you're attacking white on
the light squares because that's where
they don't have defenders
so very important when you're deciding
how to attack you look for what squares
your opponent has trouble defending or
what squares you can attack
and it's very clear that it's the light
squares that white struggles
more than the dark scores it's usually
one color or the other
so h3 what do we do now
so bishop takes h3 is very tempting here
but the problem is after g takes queen
d7 somehow we don't have mate
we can give these checks and the king
comes up and actually we even could be
in trouble here because if knight f5 the
king goes back
so somehow this just doesn't quite work
so we have to be a little bit more
nuanced with how we go about our
business
knight f3 check i see is a move but here
maybe we can actually take this guy i
don't know
the idea being that if you go for this
now at least i have king here followed
by rook g1 i feel like i'm actually
defending a little bit
this also looks of course very dangerous
but
so bishop f3 is actually
very very strong here and the idea is
that if we take it
now we play queen d7 we just ignore the
pawn because queen takes
h3 it cannot be allowed king here and
now we have another move which again is
really really nice
so yeah queen f5 is a really nice move
here
and uh it turns out that white just
can't defend against any of this
if you try knight g1 of course i just
play queen g5
um moving the king up doesn't help so
you just have no defense to all this
attack
so it's just kind of a nice little cool
subtle idea very difficult to find
though knight g3
you can now take go back um
but believe it or not like
it's very very
it's very very difficult to actually win
here so
so um
yeah so i yeah i didn't find a win here
somehow
but this was kind of a cool idea
so yeah it was one of those things where
i was playing through this lines and it
was like
you know i was trying to find stuff on
my own and then you know you have to
computer check it when you're
doing it for a lecture and it was like i
i couldn't believe that there was no win
like it just looked it was almost hard
to believe
but somehow
yeah there was just no way to win
because your queen's attacked there was
nothing you could do
but this at least was a way to i mean
secure a draw
keep in mind though wesley basically
blundered by getting his bishop trapped
on b4
so the fact that you can get a draw in
this way is still kind of remarkable
right
king h1 may have also been a possibility
and now the idea is that on bishop g4 h3
now the kings better place so you don't
get knight takes f3 with checks so f5 is
maybe a move
and then just trying to kamikaze this
way
um but this is like this was one of the
most crazy lines this is obviously
computer right knight takes here
so rook takes f4 is a huge threat and
this attack is very strong you have
bishop g4 coming
so you must play this and again warning
this is computer stuff but this line was
so crazy
takes takes bishop d2
and
the idea is that it looks like your
bishop's going to get trapped
but somehow it doesn't rook 81 allows
bishop a6
and somehow if your rook moves and rook
takes f2
so the knight goes back bishop a6
king g1 and now of course if you just
take the knight takes your bishop's
trapped again
but you play this move you just say
whatever half my bishop
and you take on b3 and this is actually
an unclear position
so i just could not believe this line it
was just so
crazy uh could you play f3 instead of
h3 i don't know which position you're
talking about unfortunately that's the
thing
when you have uh a lot of lines it's
pretty tough
but this is all obviously computer stuff
like i just wanted to show because the
lines are so crazy here
and these players trying to figure it
out
uh it's got to be really hard but yeah
the net on a4 is a little bit awkward
and it's just kind of a tricky position
i don't know how much wesley saw it's a
game in 15 so i don't think he could
have seen all of it but
um just the idea of knight h4 and just
letting the piece go is very resourceful
and the amount of tactics there are in
this position is crazy
crazy because again i'm fairly sure he
just blundered this i don't think that
it was like all planned
so uh knight g3 was what he played
instead
so once again guys let's continue our
attack knight g3 makes a lot of sense
right you're just trying to shield that
king
uh objectively i don't think it's the
best defense but it's very
understandable from a human point of
view i'd say the main drawback to it is
that it doesn't help control the g2 and
f3 squares
it shields the king from the g file but
it doesn't control g2 and f3
which is where the weaknesses really are
so again if you have a move try to
accompany it with some kind of variation
so bishop h3 takes h3 i mean there's got
to be a follow-up somehow
so one thing i would say is that this
idea i don't know i think
uh nikolai's idea is very good against
this because now
i think even a move like f5 comes to
mind
f3 sorry or maybe f4 i don't know one of
those two moves
but the idea is that i i once i'm able
to kind of
do something like this and i get my
queen in it's much harder to checkmate
me now
just for example right because you see
how my queen participates in the defense
knight f3 runs into rook takes f3
so an idea like f4 kind of comes into
mind now and
you can try net f3 check first of course
but i don't know i mean i can still play
um
maybe king g2 is wise but like even if i
go for something like this
and then just kind of put my rook on g2
it's actually very very difficult for
you to crack this because
again i'm just my rooks on g2 just kind
of defends against everything
and it makes life kind of difficult
so he came up with a slightly different
idea
so i think that was probably nikolai's
idea he was very nervous about bishop h3
and his move does defend against it
quite well and it prevents bishop g4
but it does allow some other ideas
queen d7 with the idea of knight takes
g2 and queen three it feels a little
one-dimensional like
you're kind of really hoping you get a
bunch of moves in a row
and the fact is that after a move like
this i can think about f3 again or even
f4 right
uh and i'm not so convinced that you're
going to be able to give checkmate with
just those pieces
so his idea was slightly different
one of the important things when you're
attacking and i find that players who
are really really strong
attackers like wesley obviously is is
that they know when to switch fronts
so he played knight h4 to go for this
bishop h3 or bishop g4 knight takes g2
stuff
right but the really great attackers
know that
you can't be that stubborn there are
times when
your original plan of attack is not
going to work because of how your
opponent reacted
but they've weakened something else so
knight g3 guarded against a lot of these
ideas
but it doesn't guard against another
idea of blacks
bishop a6 is possible but then you're
just trying to trade in right so for
example if i play a3 bishop takes f1
queen takes f1
you're losing both of your bishops for a
rook and a pawn and i'd say that's a
very bad trade for you i'd say that the
pieces should be a lot better than the
rooks in that situation
so i'm not so convi i'm not so crazy
about a move like bishop basics
but yeah the bishop on b4 is most likely
to be a goner
also i'm seeing something in the chat
and uh you know there might be people
here
this lecture is not really designed for
beginning test players players who are
just starting out
uh if you are even just trying to learn
to move the pieces or are just past that
i would say
uh there are definitely lots of
resources lots of websites
chess.com leeches they all have lots of
them so if you go exploring
you can definitely find a lot of
resources on the web on those websites
on other websites
but i would say that this particular
lecture is more geared towards like
intermediate to advanced players
just a heads up so if you're just
learning if you just learned how to move
the pieces or if you're just starting
out
uh obviously you're more than welcome to
watch and make suggestions but
i'm i would say that it's uh it's not
really a lecture design for you
so so guys you're
you're very uh you're very attached to
this bishop d2 move which is kind of
cool
but i'm not even obligated to take that
thing am i
it's a cool idea don't get me wrong but
let's say after bishop d2
i decided to just play king h1 are you
really doing anything to me
because now i might take the bishop
because if bishop h3 i can probably also
take it
so i'm not really convinced that you're
actually achieving anything with this
it's a really fancy idea it's a really
cool idea
but his way of playing is much simpler
and great wolf uh
provided it it's f4 f5 so
his idea is very simple he's just going
to play f4 and
bring another piece into the attack keep
in mind before we were d we were just
attacking with our knight bishop and
queen which is kind of cool but
it's hard to rely on just those pieces
to give checkmate right
it's really not an easy thing so this
idea of f5 f4
helps open up lines and bring more
pieces into the attack
but again this is kind of one of the
things that those great attackers do
they don't just get hung up on one
attacking idea like oh i want to make
bishop h3 work it's such a cool idea
but you have to have the flexibility to
be like okay that idea doesn't work
because what my opponent did let me
change it up and this idea of f5
f4 is an example of changing it up
um and again bishop e1 is kind of a cool
move i'm not sure i can't take that but
even then king h1 right like you're
you're
you're trying to find really fancy ideas
to make bishop h3 work but the fact is
that
switching up to f5 f4 is just kind of a
nice way to do it
so a3
was played i mean he has to kind of try
to trap that bishop here um
there's no real way to defend against f4
that's so great here
um it's just kind of coming in and then
the rook's going to be very strong
if bishop c1 even g5 f4 i can definitely
consider because the pawns are just
going to be so powerful
so he just tries to take the bishop
which i think is sensible
so here
and now e takes f4
and in this position this is where he
has a wide choice and i'd say that it
was wesley's
um apart from i guess the opening maybe
missing c5 or whatever
apart from that it was mainly his only
real mistake that he made this game
because he didn't find the most accurate
continuation here the question is
can you guys so black to play
and keep in mind i'm not i'm i get once
again i i say this every time i am not
looking for one move i'm looking for
uh a variation an idea something a
little bit deeper so again if
you just see one move it it doesn't
really mean anything it's very easy to
suggest the correct move
but if you see the continuation that's
what's different
yeah the problem with f4 for white by
the way i saw this question
asked that instead of a3 for example if
you try to play f4
you're just kind of opening up your own
king so i do this and i take and you're
you're just opening up lines to your own
king so i would say that this is
probably not a good course of action
so we're here so the question is how do
you play in this position
i can tell arjun's hung up on this
bishop d2 idea it is a pretty cool one
i'll admit that
yeah the winning line is very cool but
it is very complicated
very complicated so if you guys are
given two move variations you're
probably not close
and i don't expect you guys to see it
all this would be really difficult
wesley missed it you know again gaming
15 right so you have to take it with a
grain of salt but the fact is that this
is not an easy line
so if i'm seeing moves of one or two
move variations you're probably not in
the right ballpark just so you guys know
it is a very very difficult line
it's one that wesley missed and uh
well that says a lot by itself
yeah so knight f3 gf i'm pretty sure i
can then take on e4 if you give me
another move and my light squares are
improving maybe then play f3
seems like i'm defending there
uh rook f4 is possible
uh but maybe then i can take the bishop
i don't know if you actually have mate
uh moves like bishop c1 also can
sometimes help defend
rook takes f4 is kind of a natural
follow-up but there's actually much
stronger it turns out
but precision is key because you have
you want to do it while giving white the
fewest options that you
you can
so great wolf i would say that this is
actually like i
i the way i prepare stuff is i look at
it without a computer first
and then i will usually use a computer
to check my variations to make sure that
i'm not making any mistakes i usually
will mention when a line is very
computery
this line is definitely has some of that
i would say that i i wanted to play this
idea but i would not be 100 sure that it
works
um but the main thing i'm looking for
here is again like not that you're gonna
see every single line it's
almost impossible more that you see like
the idea because once you see the idea
it actually becomes a little easier and
it's a very believable idea
um what's really funny is i'd say the
movie played in the game looks more
computery than
the move that actually wins
uh but definitely it's something like i
find that if you just go over these
games with the computer you learn very
little like you have to look at over
with your own eyes and see what you see
because again a lot of the times
you know the computer will make me look
like an idiot but the fact is that
when you when you play a game yourself
and you're looking over if you want to
learn something you have to see what you
see because that's what you'd see during
a game
and you can check your work later with
the computer see how accurate you are
but the fact is that if you just look
over stuff with a computer at least in
my experience you learn very little
if you just play over your games with a
computer like you're just not learning
much
because it's just telling you things
right you might learn what mistakes you
made but you won't learn
how the position really works like how
what led to those mistakes
uh it's one of the biggest mistakes i
see people make i think and it's so
tempting because it's so much easier
than doing it the right way by looking
it over yourself but
um so again a game like this i i
definitely looked it over for my with my
own eyes
but uh i definitely checked the
variations of the computer because it's
so complicated and i wanted to show you
guys what was objectively correct
at least for this particular lecture
there's somewhere i just present
what i see and i'll make mistakes and
that's normal even with the computer of
course it's possible as well but
i wanted to show you guys what uh the
correct lines were as well
so okay uh knight takes g2
and queen h4 definitely makes a lot of
sense uh it's very close
um but the key is you have to figure out
a couple things first of all
what are the weak points in white's
position second of all what pieces do
you need to attack them
and these are kind of the important
questions you have to ask yourself here
uh and one of the things i need to
reiterate for you guys is that i'm not
obligated to take the bishop i probably
will but it's not
a necessity so if you're relying on
playing several moves in a row
assuming i'm gonna take the bishop just
keep that in mind
um that being said i think on most moves
i am gonna have to take that guy
so yeah like i'm looking at these lines
like knight g2 queen h4 they definitely
look tempting but keep in mind i can
sacrifice pieces back
so even if you play like even after
queen h4 maybe i could think about just
taking your bishop with the idea that
the second you put a bishop on g4 i'm
playing f3 and just sacking back
uh sacrificing pieces back is something
which you have to be always aware of as
a defensive resource
knight g6 takes f4 i would just define
it as too slow you're already done a
piece and that's
a heck of a that's two moves to maybe
make your knight better maybe not so i
would say that it's just too slow
so let me see like for example if you
play queen take uh
knight takes g2 let me see this one so i
think i have to take it queen h5 i mean
maybe f5 is a move but i'm kind of
curious what happens if i just take
stuff you can play bishop h3
uh but then i go back probably g1 and
i'm kind of curious how you're going to
make me here bishop g4 i'm going to play
f3
i have no qualms whatsoever sacrificing
material bag
so maybe i'm missing something here but
i do not see the mate
and mainly the reason is because f3 is
coming so
if you play rook takes f4 i have f3 if
bishop g4 i play f3
and i i just don't see how you're gonna
deliver mate here
i think that as soon as the f3 move
happens and i can guard h2 along the
second rank it's going to be almost
impossible
so
that is not correct but again
it's understandable it's tempting but i
would say that one of the main things
you have to realize there is that
the the bishop is actually not helping
you enough
like it looks really nice but it's a
little clumsy you have to go h3 you have
to go g4 like
the bishop as strong as it looks is
actually not the most powerful piece and
not the one you need
so
again i'm missing all your lines but i
do know what is the only winning line
here
so um but yeah i mean
the to to refute all of this is is very
difficult right like this is not
it's so easy imagine in a game in 15
having to come up with this
so i'll kind of i'll kind of move you
guys along a little bit bishop h3
is the correct starting move but the key
is to spot the idea after i take what is
your key idea here
and it's funny because it almost like to
me like i play bug house sometimes it
reminds me of bug house concepts that
if you allow the move f3 your opponent
defends so much easier sometimes because
they can guard the second rake they can
guard the g2 square
obviously in bug house it's a lot worse
because pieces get dropped on you but
the the same concept is there that you
often have to prevent
your opponent from being able to kind of
create space for their guys to be able
to create space to defend
so the same concept applies here you
play knight f3 check
and this gets extremely complicated but
the main idea is that you're gonna
target the h3 pawn
and you're gonna do it now with a knight
on f3 that completely blocks out all of
white's play
and unlike in some of the previous lines
we saw playing king h so for example if
you try to play king h1 and rook g1
this position is actually
completely indefensible and the main
reason is because you're not just
attacking with a queen and knight
you can bring your rook in so you have a
very very accurate course of action here
uh and keep in mind that it takes like
the video is definitely
a little bit behind me so it's gonna
take me a while to
get your moves
so rook takes f4 as possible but you
actually have a more accurate way to
play
to give you an idea i think if you play
rook takes f4 uh i believe i can play
pontek's bishop and the idea is that if
you try rook h4 now i can play knight f1
and i think i'm defending
it's crazy as it is so you have to be
very very accurate here
so rook f6 and rook 4 have the same idea
again it's about accurate move orders
guys
that's what you're trying to look for
here
and look for your most threatening moves
as well
so a lot of you are suggesting bishop b1
but the fact is the bishop e1 does not
make a threat
i'd like i'd like to make a threat if i
can
and this is a good habit for you guys to
get into in general always look at your
threatening moves first
if your threatening moves don't work you
go to your more subtle moves that we've
talked about
but always look for your most
threatening moves first
plane 81 you use the fact your bishop is
still alive somehow
guarding the pawn uh guarding the knight
rather
and it's actually quite annoying so
queen take c1 is actually a forced move
now
and then after something like this the
b3 pawn is going to be quite weak
so rook g1 uh looks like
uh the force move because obviously you
don't want to sack your queen but here
you get brutally
checkmated so you play rook takes f4
and in this position there are a couple
key points
if rook takes e2 e1 you just take on f2
and you're threatening two mates in one
queen g2 and queen h2 that's pretty hard
to stop
and you have another mate threat in two
here
what would that be
oh for sure you need a long time to see
all this i'm not expecting any of you to
see all this he didn't see all this and
he's like 27
450 you know like this is really really
complicated stuff
um but the key is more it's still good
training to try to look for it
and to try to spot your ideas but you
can see how
it's so easy for you guys to just play
rook takes f4 without thinking right
but you play knight e1 first dislodges
the rook so then rook takes f4 has two
threats you're threatening rook takes f2
and what's the other one very nice so
for example
if i play queen e2 guarding against rook
takes f2
bam now that is a cool way
and stylish way to end the game
but you see why 91 is so much stronger
than playing rook takes f4 first right
so you can see why this works because
the knight on e1
it threatens rook takes f2 and threatens
work takes e1 h4
so really really cool stuff uh however
king g2 is probably a slightly more uh
stubborn defense
but the idea now is that after rook
takes f4 we're still gonna target that
h3 pawn
and it's really really tough to deal
with so for example
if white plays bishop c1 we play rook h4
so once again we're just going to play
queen d7 and storm here
i think we call it anastasia's mate in
english as well yeah
i don't know the names of checkmates
very well or openings or anything like
that
i mean i know them but i don't know the
names uh all that
all that well so you'll have to forgive
me but i do believe that is anastasia's
mate
so here um
somehow it's just really really bad so
like knight f5 for example is a move but
we just go here and then we can take
which is kind of funny so rook h1 is the
move that i wanted to play i thought
that this was the most uh
human defense so queen d7
is very logical trying to take on h3
king here
and this is where things get really cool
uh and i think you guys given how you've
been suggesting moves you guys have a
good shot at finding this so i'll give
you a shot black has a really really
amazing idea here but i'm not just
looking for the move i'm looking for the
idea that's the hard part
i'm seeing queen h5 instead of queen but
queen takes h2 gave mate
so qui takes h2 is pretty good in that
line i don't know if that's what we're
referring to
um e2 is not something any oh
queen could have gone yeah queen could
have gone to
[Music]
try to remember the position anyway um
let's try to focus on this one for now
but yeah i mean that one was made after
rook takes so
um but after queen h5 uh i can play rook
h4
and win the queen there i believe
ah that's a cool concept actually but
the problem is after queen a six check
queen e2 you probably just go back right
uh it's a really cool idea though
queenie two actually yeah effect
i play i i knew him from a tournament in
the netherlands i played him there
uh i played him once and i play i saw
him at two tournaments a really really
nice guy and amazing studies uh he has
um so i enjoyed hanging out with afek
like he really really uh
really really cool studies and uh just
fun to look at chess with you know
that's cool you know him though it's a
friend of yours yeah really really uh
cool guy
so queen h3 is kind of like the auto
move right which looks like it has to be
it
but somehow after king e2 it's actually
not so easy to give checkmate here the
king's kind of trying to run maybe
bishop e3 next maybe queen f1 king d1 i
don't know
the bishop still hangs
yeah the end game studies he has are
really amazing
but this move by itself is also quite
amazing white to black to play here you
have to think like how do i
like shatter white's king position uh
and also serve a function that's kind of
the tricky one
and this was obviously one which i was
not found by me
um so you're looking for a computer-ish
move
but it's still really really pretty the
whole idea
uh yeah i don't think you win the queen
there
uh because after knight g1 i can take
with the queen if i need to
um it's a really cool idea though
really really cool idea so what he's
saying is queen h3 check king e291
knight g1 checks the idea is that after
takes you can go here and then take the
queen that is really awesome
uh but i think i can take with queen can
i
and then if queen g4 check i play king
f1
looks horrible but i don't see a mate
wouldn't be surprised if you have a mate
though
yeah knight g1 that's cool that's a
really awesome move well
yeah you can go back to c8 as well but
then i think maybe i can move my queen
and go king d1 and
pretend i'm still alive
the move here believe it or not is
bishop e1
so the whole concept is that it took me
a second to figure this out
is that you want to take the pawn on f2
and then play rook f8 and then the king
will have no defenders
so for example if you play king e2 i
just take this guy
rookie rook f8 queen takes and you're
just getting slaughtered
because queen g2 is a threat because
your whole position is falling apart
you just have no way to defend against
all these threats
so bishop e3 was what i thought should
defend
uh that was the move that i thought was
logical but apparently bishop takes f2
anyway
and we're still getting wrecked because
queen g2 is coming
um and we just have no defense to any of
this like that we're just losing our
bishop
e3 is in the air sometimes
and our king just has no defenders
yeah it was amazing that the bishop on
b4 came in to be such an important piece
so pretty cool but yeah this is really
hard to find this is not stuff that's
human being can find
so i've got to focus uh we're coming to
the end here so i'm just going to focus
on one more moment where i'll ask you a
question
so bishop d2 is actually what he played
which a lot of you wanted to do it looks
fancy but it's actually not as accurate
because now noritsen
gets back in the game queen takes d2
bishop h3 and f3 once again
as i said this is a really key defensive
idea it's one that comes from bug house
a lot like this happens at bug outs all
the time f3
you kind of can have some room for your
king
um and it applies in this game as well
so f3
um and now norton's totally in the fight
here takes
and they get just a very unclear
position he sacks back to exchange
knight back to c3 so noritsen here has
what is material here he has
um two pieces for the rook so he's doing
okay
even pawns but obviously his king's
still not ideal so
wesley plays the really spectacular
looking rook takes f4
and the key here is should noritsen take
the rook
or should he not take the rook and i'll
let you guys decide i'll give you a
couple minutes
take the rook or not to take the rook
but yeah so much in this game and this
is one where like again you can analyze
this whole
position for so many hours like the one
before
but this was a really key moment uh here
so do you take that rock on f4 or do you
not what do you guys think
we have one vote to take it
well we have lots of votes on both sides
here
uh no this is not ding this is noritzen
against wesley so
so it's very important that you have to
know
when you can when pieces are safe to
capture and when they're not
so in this particular case i think it's
absolutely necessary to take the rook
and the reason why is because after
takes check
rook f8 you can actually play this move
knight f5
and now black and sack
but the fact is that there's nothing
here apart from just a perp
you just go back and forth the kid could
go to different places you of course
don't want to go
to ef2 because you allow e3 check
winning the queen
but you just basically just have to
accept a perp after this
and i'm guessing that he just missed
this concept
so i don't see matzo take it believe it
or not that's actually not a bad policy
when you're under attack
because if you take the rook they at
least have to meet you or do something
like this so yeah
there's nothing better than a perpetual
here um
knight c takes e4 was maybe a slightly
better try than what he did but even
here queen h4
you double rooks and this position is
also very very difficult
he ended up playing rookie one which
looks very logical but now after queen
h4
he's basically just dead because d5 he
plays rook g4
he's ready to sack on g3 with rook f8
coming
the game is basically over so he tries
to defend but it's basically impossible
he loses the knight due to the queen g2
may threat
so he lost it a few moves after this so
he could even play rook g4 again but he
decides to be simple and just
defend against the pawn and with h4
coming the
d pawn not moving the game was over
so even though it looked like a really
dangerous piece to take it looked like a
piece that
you know oh my goodness i can't take
this rook wesley i'm playing wesley he
for sure is gonna make me after that
but as you saw there's just no sometimes
there's just no mates
and what that means is that you had to
do that
um so
again like there were lots of variations
there like it's not it's not
like super simple but the fact is that
there are times when you just have to
take that piece because
if there's no mate there's no mate so
the key the key line there was that
after takes takes king f1 rook f8
there's knight here
so yeah i mean if if queen d3 check you
just you can go to e1 and it takes f5
you recapture and you don't really have
a choice but to take that knight at some
point
so again it was just kind of a really
important moment but you saw how this
game was so complicated he didn't play
it perfectly
he even got his bishop trapped in the
opening but he used his resourcefulness
his tactical vision with knight h4
bishop
bishop out he uh found ways to get back
in the game and
the pressure you know his opponent
defended really well for a stretch there
but
it's just so hard to defend against
relentless pressure for a long period of
time
and i think it's one of the reasons why
wesley does so well against
lower rated gm's or strong ims in this
case
because it's just so much pressure to
have to deal with and
the very top players might be able to do
this and get away with the draw or get
away with a win but
for players who are not quite that good
to put up that kind of pressure is
really tough
so the idea i guess would be to
kind of apply this to your own games as
well
anyway again i know that there are lots
of variations here um
i did check these with computers so i'm
fairly sure they're correct but at the
same time
it's hard to not have unanswered
questions in these kind of lines so
it's uh there are plenty of lines i was
seeing as i was playing over it before
before what i was playing over when i
prepared the lecture afterwards
and honestly you could spend so much
time and we spent a lot of time earlier
in the game
uh trying to figure these things out but
in any case uh i hope you guys enjoyed
the lecture
and uh stick around
uh well not stick around tonight but
i'll definitely be
at the club for the next few days still
not literally at the club but i'll be
doing live streams and stuff like that
but i hope you enjoyed the lecture and i
will see you guys around thanks for
tuning in
you